camera Nellie revisiting painful
memories - in the home that she shares
with the sister nice manawa suburbia
looks at photos of a wedding four years
ago
Oba Navin and her family had to pay a
hefty dowry but her in-laws and husband
didn't think it was enough they harassed
and abused ossifer finally her husband
Kamran Ali uttered the word the lock or
divorced three times over the phone news
Muhammad ending the marriage of over a
year in the space of a few seconds Asif
upper beam was pregnant at the time
turned to the police but they couldn't
do much Muslim marriages are usually not
registered and there is no law banning
instant herbals I was shell-shocked I
thought what's going to happen to me my
life is in limbo I don't know where I'm
supposed to stay what I'm supposed to do
what will happen to my daughter it's a
situation that Nia's meme is all too
familiar with the 29 year old works in
Islam in South Delhi she wants to raise
awareness about the practice of verbal
divorce among Muslims and mobilize women
i'm lisa lavie today she meets this
group most women here a poor uneducated
and were married off young Salma Begum
is 22 she suffered years of torture by
her in-laws ending up in hospital with
serious injuries and almost completely
losing her eyesight a few months ago her
husband divorced her over the phone and
took the younger of Salma's two children
with him but Danny my husband said I
can't see any more
I can't walk properly I even need help
to go to the bathroom that's why he
divorced me he doesn't want me in
Nia's mean says widespread illiteracy
and the stranglehold of patriarchy
leaves women highly vulnerable when they
abandoned I'd jump mile ago worried
women have absolutely no rights the left
with nothing cap jelly outside is in me
that is a man just says the lock or
divorce three times and walks away just
like that I use gear I was Diego use
free of all responsibilities he just
uses a woman and then dumps her he
doesn't pay any maintenance towards his
own children this is a huge problem in
the Muslim community hamari Muslims are
modern medical kre the issue is
triggered intense debate in India the
country's top court is reviewing the
matter amid growing calls to ban the
practice but not everyone agrees the mid
17th century Fateh puri mosque is a
famous landmark in old delhi human
rights the Imam of the mosque moved the
Mukarram Hamid sister Berthe luck is an
issue of faith and personal law and
cannot be tampered with there should be
no change in a Muslim person law which
is Sharia this is God's law it's based
on the Quran and on the prophets sales
job women know very well that in the
Sharia if there's a marriage they could
well be a divorce if you don't like it
why get married in the first place there
should be no outside interference in our
faith but that doesn't fly anymore with
women like a super Barbie she wants a
man on top of the log and a tough
penalty for vendors so that her daughter
is spared a similar ordeal when she
grows up